foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
we will be looking ahead at next week's
episode the name of episode 4 is the
king of the narrow sea a name also given
to Daemon Targaryen after his victory
over the crab feeder and his men as you
can see Daemon has now arrived back in
King's Landing with a crown of his own
on his head if you've read Fire and
Blood then you know it was Laura corla's
valerion who actually set the crown on
Damon's head one thing you should
immediately notice is how much shorter
Damon Sarah is in the scene it will be
another way of showing how much time has
gone by since the last episode it was
aegon's second name day in the last
episode but in this episode we hear them
say he's now three years old in this
shot we see Daemon walking into the
Great Hall of the red keep in King's
Landing he has a little bit of swagger
in his step as he rolls right up to the
Iron Throne viserys looks visibly upset
at Damon's arrival not only because he
now has a crown on his head but also
because he has named himself a king
among many other things this will most
likely be seen as another sign of
disrespect from his brother as if Damon
and viserys haven't had enough issues
with one another already like we have
heard Daemon say before he loves getting
a reaction out of his brother and he
will certainly get one from him here now
if you've seen all the other trailers
then you know Daemon isn't welcomed with
open arms we have seen the lower
commander of the kingsguards sir Harold
westerling shoving his sword into
Damon's armor stopping him from moving
forward any further with all of these
eyes on viserys watching him as this
goes down he will have to discipline
Damon in some way now if they do follow
George R Martin's novel Fire and Blood
in this scene we should see Damon remove
the crown from his head in offer it to
viserys that might win over some of the
Lords and Ladies in the room but will it
be enough to win over his King we shall
see now this new trailer actually opens
up with the scene of rhaenyra holding
the Valyrian steel dagger over an open
flame as the blade gets red hot it
reveals a hidden message on the Valerian
Steel
from my blood come the prince that was
promised
his will be the Song
of Ice and Fire
once again rhaenyra learns about the
significance of her bloodline it's a
reminder that someone from House
Targaryen will be needed in the future
to stop the deadly threat that lies
north Beyond the Wall if you remember in
Game of Thrones this was the same thing
that Melisandre was obsessed with the
Lord of Light was giving her a very
similar message
the prince he was promised to bring the
dawn
this is also the same thing that drove
rhaegar Targaryen many believe this is
what led him to lyanna Stark and since
how Stark has seen as ice since her from
the north in-house Targaryen has seen as
fire many would say that Jon Snow was
The Song of Ice and Fire either way they
all knew someone down the line would
have to unite all of Westeros in order
to defeat the white walkers viserys
might use this as a way of making
rhaenyra understand that she needs to
not only get married but start having
sons of her own we've heard her say she
doesn't want to get married and she's
even hinted at the fact that she doesn't
want to have her own kids but maybe now
she will see that this is much bigger
than her in some of these other scenes
we will eventually see rhaenyra go out
and look for a suitable match in the
last episode vasera said she could go
and find someone herself and that's
exactly what we see her do in the new
episode in one shot we see her sailing
on a ship heading for an unknown
destination I think this might be when
she's sailing for Storm's end we see her
here sitting in the high seat of house
Baratheon on one side is sir Kristen
Cole a member of her father's kingsguard
as well as her own guard and on the
other side is Borman Baratheon the Lord
of Storm's end and the head of house
Baratheon since renero is looking for a
husband she's seeing what storm Zen has
to offer it doesn't look like Rainier
will find a match soon enough because
viserys gets very angry with her once
again in a different scene we hear him
say your courtship is at an end he must
be getting frustrated with how long
she's taking which will most likely lead
to him finding her a match himself what
will eventually make this even worse is
once the disgusting rumors start
circulating around King's Landing about
rhaenyra's extracurricular activities we
find out about this when Serato
Hightower delivers the discomforting
news shortly after renera finds out
someone is making vile accusations about
her and most likely her uncle Daemon
Targaryen I have discomforting news
is a vile accusation who is responsible
for this gossip I will take their eye
in some of the other scenes we do see
rhaenyra and Daemon sneaking around the
city of King's Landing at night I'm
thinking this might be when Damon starts
taking ranera around to the different
brothels within the city and Fire and
Blood it's said that Damon starts
introducing her to the art of seduction
by letting her watch others have sex he
might even let ranera watch him a
massario in another scene we see
someone's hands on the wall as they're
most likely having sex that ring on the
man's finger is the same one we see
Damon wearing earlier in the episode now
it's really hard to say who this might
be with Damon because he's known for
sleeping around with so many different
ladies it might be masaria some other
[ __ ] or even rhaenyra herself either
way someone must find out about this or
see them inside one of the brothels and
get word back to the hand of the king
Serato Hightower must love this because
he can use the accusations to help aegon
get on the Iron Throne we see how he has
his eyes set on the iron throne in the
new video he already made it known to
his daughter Allison aegon will be the
king one way or another
the road ahead is uncertain but the end
is clear
aegon will be king
if you ask me Serato will stop at
nothing to make sure that happens now
that visiris and rhaenyra are always at
odds with one another I do wonder if
they will have him named aegon as his
Heir we already heard what he said to
Allison in the last episode he wonders
if naming raniera as his Heir was a
mistake what will make things even
Messier is the introduction of a saris
and Ella sends other children we see
Allison finally had their second child a
daughter named Helena Targaryen as of
right now Allison is still standing by
her friend or I should say former friend
in renero Not only was she still on her
side in the last episode but it seems
she still has her back in the next
episode as well we hear Alison say it is
not anywhere near as nature to be
deceitful but I cannot say the same
about your brother this is suggesting
that Damon is up to more of his
Shenanigans I think he will end up
forcing viserys to have him exiled from
King's Landing once again as much as he
does love his brother he only ends up
creating more issues for viserys
whenever he's around Damon is shown
flying on car access again when he
swoops down over Rainier's ship this
might be when he leaves King's Landing
in search of a match for himself we will
eventually see Damon get married very
soon but I won't say to who just yet
after watching the new trailer one thing
is for sure everything is disintegrating
around viserys Targaryen he was already
an absolute mess in that last episode
and now it seems he's only getting
weaker by the day his days are almost
numbered and like I've said before the
downfall of House Targaryen has begun
after watching everything unfold it
seems like the next episode might be the
best one of the season so far it's
really starting to feel like those Glory
Days of Game of Thrones I think the
series was at its best when every
character's life has flipped upside down
I don't know about all of you but I
really look forward to the next episode
I think the show will only get better
from here on out let me know what all of
you think down below as always I want to
thank all of you for watching this video
I hope you all have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign